pensez y en a trop de toute pièce
monsieur a chanté un centième d'euro je
vais vous montrer ses seins dans l'idiot
janvier 2002 il y a tout juste 20 ans
cela fait à peine quelques jours que les
français ont des centimes d'euro dans
leur porte-monnaie et déjà ils râlent
avec la victoire de loin je vois pas les
flics et de frais en sus de trop
beaucoup trop pour certains ce n'est pas
bien on est un peu perdu avec des pièces
en croatie verte mais l'essentiel face à
cette grogne dès janvier les
journalistes s'interrogent les pièces de
1 et 2 centimes d'euro vont elles
disparaître de la circulation
si aucune décision dans ce sens n'a
encore été prise la question alimente de
plus en plus les conversations trois
semaines après leur apparition ces
pièces sont loin de faire l'unanimité
auprès des consommateurs trop petit
encombrante et peu pratique pour régler
ses achats les arguments sont nombreux
oui mais voilà deux clans s'opposent
ceux qui veulent voir disparaître ces
petites pièces est arrondir les prix et
ceux défendus par des associations de
consommateurs qui craignent que les
prises arrondi n'entraîne une
augmentation des visites et si les
consommateurs se plaignent de ces
centimes les professionnels ils seront
tous contents d'arrondir mais il faut
bien se dire qu'ils vont pas arrondir à
la baisse qui vont à rebondir
au dessus un pour faire des prix ronds
donc si l'intérêt des consommateurs
d'accepter ces petites pièces et de les
manipuler d'apprendre à les manipuler
c'est pas très difficile les années
passent et chacun reste campé sur ses
positions
jusqu'en 2013 où la question de la
survie de ces centimes se pose au plus
haut niveau à la commission européenne
avec un nouvel argument le coût de
production de ces pièces cuivre et en
fait les pièces de un ou deux centimes
coûte cher à la fabrication elle coûte
environ 3 centimes en moyenne donc un
coup de plus cher que ce qu'elles valent
et par ailleurs les gens ne les utilise
pas vraiment il les garde côtes et elles
sont trop encombrante donc aujourd'hui
on se pose la question est ce que ces
pièces sont utiles bruxelles continue de
plancher sur le sujet en attendant des
pays comme la belgique la finlande les
pays-bas ou l'irlande ont déjà répondu à
cette question en arrondissant tous
leurs prix afin de ne plus utiliser les
pièces de 1 et 2 centimes
[Musique]